si monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à bruno
le maire -ministre de l'économie et des
finances il est parti monsieur le
ministre le 19 décembre dernier à
quelques jours de noël le président de
la république s'adressait depuis abidjan
à la communauté française
il s'adressait à travers eux à plus de 3
millions de français qui résident à
l'étranger
ces français si souvent oublié qu'ils ne
croient depuis bien longtemps plus au
père noël
le président de la république leur a
promis de s'attaquer aux pratiques de
des bancarisation par les banques
françaises
vous y étiez il leur a promis et je le
cite que les banques françaises qui sont
heureuses de trouver l'état français
pour les accompagner dans les projets à
l'extérieur et pour trouver de beaux
projets de financement seraient
convoqués ce sont ses mots pour trouver
une solution
monsieur le ministre comme ces millions
de français qui ont entendu ses
promesses à quelques jours de noël
je n'ai pas été vraiment surpris de voir
qu'il n'y avait rien le 25 décembre au
pied du sapin
il n'avait rien alors que depuis 2013 et
les premières fermetures de comptes de
manière arbitraire la situe la situation
n'a cessé de se détériorer
il n'y avait rien alors qu'à chacun de
mes déplacements à l'étranger
je suis interpellé par ces français qui
me font part de leur désarroi et de leur
incompréhension
monsieur le ministre est il normal que
ces français soient contraints de se
tourner vers des banques étrangères pour
ouvrir un compte ou chercher des
financements
cette situation inacceptable n'a que
trop duré les français l'étranger sont
fatigués d'entendre toujours les mêmes
promesses
il ne supporte plus cette stigmatisation
ils ne supportent plus d'être une
variable d'ajustement de voir la
fiscalité augmenté pendant que les
services consulaires voir le peu à peu
leurs moyens diminués monsieur le
ministre les français ne croient plus au
père noël
ils veulent garder l'espoir l'espoir
d'être entendus nous sommes le 29
janvier il est encore temps ont formulé
un voeu
ma question est donc simple allez-vous
exaucé enfin le voeu des français de
l'étranger en luttant réellement contre
les pratiques de des bancarisation
comme vous l'a demandé président de la
république